[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up man what's up yo
[Applause]
what's up billy what's up fellas what's
up
it is an absolute pleasure
to to meet you to be on
with you and from the deepest parts of
my heart i want to say congratulations
to you uh you have the role of will on
bel-air
i'm ready i'm so ready yo i'm ready to
bite down when did you you know first
hear about it and decide to pursue the
role so my dad sent me actually this
article about it like yo you should
really do this and i was like dad that's
not how auditions work
i can't just like yeah i want to do this
you know but two two months later
my agent sent me the call and i knew
right that is beautiful man i gotta show
you a picture i remember in high school
i begged everyone to be a part of this
thing with me and we dressed up as the
as you probably can't see that's
hilarious i love that you know you got a
a
fantastic road uh ahead of you
and i'm looking forward to being an
asset for you in this process as you
build out your life and build out your
career so thank you so much
this is a dream come true you don't know
like i know you probably do know you
feel it
like this
like like the way like the show has
impacted me in my life is
incredible
i hear you say that more than honored
looking forward to it uh jabari congrats
go go have some fun thank you so much
i'm so grateful this is
incredible
[Music]
you